so for some reason discussions about
christianity often gets a bit one-sided
when most people in at least western
europe
and america think about christianity
they usually think either about the
roman catholic church
or about one of the various protestant
denominations but included in the
diverse religion of christianity
generally
is of course also what is known as the
orthodox
churches the orthodox churches represent
a form of christianity that while of
course
sharing some of the basic tenets of the
religion can sometimes appear quite
different from its western counterparts
many traditions
theologies and practices of the two
western
and eastern branches of christianity has
developed in
different directions across the
centuries which has led to some very
interesting and fascinating differences
and characteristics
unique to both of them and while the
western catholic church had a
flourishing period of mysticism
especially in the late
middle ages with figures that we've
already discussed in previous videos
like meister eckhart
or marguerite porret for example the
eastern orthodox church has
also developed a tradition of mysticism
and mystical theology
that is just as significant and
important
and one of the most important and
well-known features
of this general mysticism of the eastern
church as well as a topic that has been
frequently requested by you guys
is a tradition known as hessicasm
[Laughter]
[Applause]
over the course of the early middle ages
around the turn of the first millennium
christianity had increasingly become
divided into an
eastern part and a western part
the western part being characterized by
their use of the
latin language the exalted position of
the pope
and other theological aspects while
their eastern counterparts primarily
used the greek
language and denied the supreme position
of the pope
this is a huge generalization and the
reasons for the east-west split is very
complex and deserves a video of its own
but the gist of the story is that these
gradual differences
eventually led to the so-called great
schism of christianity
into the western roman catholic church
and the eastern
orthodox church some placed the schism
in the year
1054 but really as i've just said this
was in fact a more
gradual gradual estrangement
rather than a single event in any case
since then the two branches of
christianity
have developed independently in
different directions and in various ways
emphasizing different theological
perspectives practicing in slightly
different ways etc
now something that is important to get
out of the way early is the fact that
orthodox christianity is itself divided
into subgroups
in a general sense we often talk about
the oriental orthodox churches
which include groups like the coptic
church in egypt the armenian apostolic
church and syrian orthodox church
these quote-unquote oriental churches
are sometimes also known as
non-calcidonion churches on the basis
that they split off from the rest of the
christians by denying the creed
presented at the council of chalcedon in
451
complex theological debate aside the
other group of orthodox christianity
besides the oriental orthodox is often
called the eastern
orthodox church which has been prevailed
primarily in greece
anatolia and eastern europe especially
in russia
and in this video we will be focusing on
the eastern orthodox church in
particular
even if the oriental churches have a lot
of interesting things to offer us
hopefully in future episodes now when we
look at the eastern orthodox church and
compare it to the roman catholics
we can find a number of distinct
features especially after the official
split
while they for example share the same
early authority figures and church
fathers
the two denominations will often
emphasize or highlight
different figures as more or less
important saint augustine
perhaps the most central figure in early
theologian of the western church
does not play as important of a role in
eastern orthodoxy for example
and relatively minor figures in the
catholic traditions such as clement of
alexandria
or pseudo-dinesius the areopagites have
a more major role to play
in eastern orthodoxy and this has been
one of the reasons that these two forms
of christianity
looked quite different during the middle
ages we all know about the great
scholastic tradition of western europe
for example with figures like thomas
aquinas
peter abelard etc implementing a
strongly rationalistic approach to
theology
influenced by the greek philosophers
like aristotle
this became a central feature of the
western church the influence of which is
still apparent
the eastern orthodox church didn't have
scholasticism
instead to generalize a bit it
approached the religion and its theology
in a less rationalistic and more
mystical
way now of course the word mysticism is
a notoriously
problematic and slippery term that
i sometimes like to avoid in these kinds
of discussions but
um for the sake of this discussion we're
defining mysticism as
as opposed to the scholastic rationalism
or the rationalizing i should say
of the scholastic philosophers and
theologians the
mystic or the mysticism in this case
would be defined as
a an approach where the personal
experience of
the person and experience of the divine
is
is at its center so so to say
don't get me wrong the western church
had mysticism definitely as we've seen
with figures like eckhart
but you could say that the eastern
orthodox church were in the eastern
orthodox church
the mystical approach is even more
strongly integrated into the core
features of its theology indeed vladimir
lovski
a russian theologian of the 20th century
writes that the theology of the eastern
church
is essentially mystical quote the
eastern tradition has never made a sharp
distinction between mysticism and
theology
between personal experience of the
divine mysteries and the dogma affirmed
by the church
there is therefore no christian
mysticism without theology
but above all there is no theology
without mysticism
this is perhaps best exemplified by the
fact that according to lawsky and other
scholars
the primary goal of the christian life
the very purpose of theology and of all
religious endeavor
is ultimately to reach union with god
quote the theological doctrines which
have been elaborated in the course of
these struggles
can be treated in the most direct
relation to the vital end
that of union with god to the attainment
of which
they are subservient this union known in
greek as
theosis also translated as demonization
or more literally as
becoming divine is a particularly
central aspect of the eastern orthodox
church
and its spiritual practices including
the hesse caste tradition
which is the main subject of this video
indeed the theology of the orthodox
church follows in a line of mystically
oriented
apophatic traditions of antiquity now
what epiphaticism means is the idea that
god is
totally beyond any form of human
understanding or descriptions
in other words nothing can be said about
god
only statements about what god isn't
will suffice if even that
this apathetic approach to god was
expressed by
many of the church fathers including the
esoterically oriented clement of
alexandria who writes in his great work
the stromata
that we can't know or attain to god in
what he is
but only in what he is not but the most
significant figure in the development of
the apathetic tradition
is the figure known as the
pseudo-dionysius
a platonizing christian theologian and
philosopher who
probably lived in the 5th century in his
monumental treaties called the mystical
theology
he presents and in a way pioneers the
heavily apathetic approach to god
that would so characterize leader
mysticism in general he tells us that we
can never
know god or what he is since he is in
his very nature
unknowable instead it is through
unknowing
that we may begin to approach the
ineffable darkness of the godhead
for those of you who have read western
mystics like eckhart you will recognize
this kind of language eckhart was very
influenced by
pseudodynesis as were many other mystics
both in the eastern and western
tradition he's
very important for for the history of
both christian mysticism but also in
mysticism generally
and in apophatic theology in general
court now god is beyond all that exists
in order
to approach him it is necessary to deny
all that is inferior to him
that is to say all that which is if in
seeing god
one can know what one sees them one has
not seen god in himself but something
intelligible
something which is inferior to him it is
by
unknowing that one may know him who is
above every possible object of knowledge
proceeding by negations one ascends from
the inferior degrees of being to the
highest
by progressively setting aside all that
can be known
in order to draw near to the unknown in
the darkness of absolute ignorance
this is not just an instance of
speculative or philosophical abstraction
as epiphaticism can often become instead
for
dionysius and many of the other
theologians of his kind
the apophatic approach is very much an
active
one it is a process of purification
where the individual turns away from all
that is not god
by removing any positive attributions
and association with conceptual thoughts
and gradually enters into the darkness
and silence
where god truly dwells and where he
reaches union
in the words of timothy ware quotes in
fact many of those who used the
apophatic approach
saw it not just as a philosophical
divide for indicating god's utter
transcendence
but also and much more fundamentally as
a means of attaining union with him
through prayer and it is from this
apathetic
spiritual approach that the mystical
practices and contemplative traditions
within the eastern orthodox church
stem and probably the most famous of
these contemplative traditions
is finally what is known as hezekiasm
and thus after a very long introduction
we have finally reached the main
topic of today's episode hesikasm could
be referred to as a tradition of
meditation and prayer
that developed within the eastern
orthodox church primarily in the middle
ages
even though its origins may have roots
earlier it especially became a hot topic
of debate in the 14th century
but was a very popular way of religious
and spiritual practice before that and
especially in places like on mount athos
in greece
the contemplative ascetical tradition
has of course existed since the very
earliest days of christianity
pioneered by the desert fathers and
mothers but around the turn of the first
millennium
there had appeared significant figures
within the eastern church
that started to put down in writing some
of the meditative practices that
characterized the mysticism of the
church
one of the most important of these
figures is saint simeon the new
theologian
a byzantine mystic from constantinople
who spoke in his writings about the
mystical experience of intimacy and
union with god the title of theologian
does not simply mean that he was a
person who speculated about god which is
the kind of conventional meaning of the
word theologian
instead in this context the title
theologian
denoted someone who had a personal
direct experience of god
and of unity with him in fact this title
had only been given to
three figures of the orthodox church the
apostle john
gregory of nazianzus and finally our
friend saint simeon
this great mystic emphasized the direct
experience of god's
light and mystical unions through
turning inward in contemplation
much in the way described by
pseudo-dionysius
but in a way he is only a foretaste of
the hesicast tradition proper
now hesicasm is derived from the greek
word hasikiyah
which means inner stillness and when we
talk about hesicasm we
usually mean a certain form of
contemplative meditation
and prayer this prayer involves certain
bodily postures
breathing techniques and prayers to be
repeated the hesse cast
sought to be united to god and to
receive the grace of the holy spirit and
the trinity at large
by turning inward the meditation itself
involves sitting down with one's head
bowed
one the chin touching the breast the
chest
and one's eyes being fixated on the
place of the heart
then the breathing is also controlled
and then the breathing is
sort of done in time with the prayers
that are being recited
and indeed that last part is very
important because the
quote unquote has a caste technique of
prayer
is after all just that it's a kind of
prayer in particular the hesse cast talk
about the prayer of the heart
and this prayer usually takes the
formula of the so-called
jesus prayer this is a very short prayer
that goes as follows
lord jesus christ son of god have mercy
upon me
and in later periods the words a sinner
was added so lord jesus christ have
mercy upon me
a sinner and this prayer this
phrase would be repeated by the monks
who practiced the hesicast form of
meditation
or prayer for very long periods of time
they would repeat it over and over again
while doing also these bodily postures
that i just described
many have of course compared this form
of prayer or meditation to
other forms of meditation in other
religions like yoga for example
and while there are many similarities we
should also be careful
with making too many of those kinds of
comparisons
the orthodox scholars themselves will
often emphasize that the
bodily postures are simply an aid for
concentration and has no other
symbolic or any other function really
other than
to be a help for concentration the goal
is to receive the grace of god something
that
can't be controlled with bodily
movements themselves
the hesicasts were often criticized as
having a crude materialist approach to
spirituality
because of this kind of misunderstanding
as already said
the purpose of these contemplative
practices was to turn inward
to purify the soul of all external
things and to make that journey into the
apathetic darkness beyond all
understanding where paradoxically the
light of god is experienced
god is not to be reached out there in
the external world
but rather by turning to the innermost
parts of our own being
after all as the account in genesis says
the human being was created in the image
of god this means that we all
collectively have a divine part of
ourselves which is accessible
timothy ware writes quotes each of us is
a living theology
and because we are god's icon we can
find god by looking within our own
heart by returning within ourselves
this point is affirmed again and again
in scripture and in the writings of the
church fathers
the kingdom of god is within you says
the gospel of luke
the father of christian asceticism saint
anthony of egypt also stated that quote
he who knows himself knows god echoing a
lot of other statements made by other
major figures of different religions
even clement of alexandria writes in the
straumata that quote
when you see your brother or sister you
see god
all of us have the image of god within
ourselves a connection to the divine
that can be cultivated to the point that
we ourselves become
divinized in christian theology this was
the path that was opened up by the
person of jesus christ and his sacrifice
in the famous words of that very
significant church father athanasius
quote god became human so that we might
become god
now some of you may ask if god is so
transcendent and beyond
all created things and beyond all
understanding
how can one possibly unite with him like
what does this
uniting with god actually mean this is a
very legitimate question and a question
that a lot of
christians and eastern orthodox church
christians asked
at the time or still do but also back in
medieval times
this was a question that came up in
particular when the hezekiah claimed
that they had experienced
god's light in this experience of
mystical intimacy
that seemed to go against the central
doctrine of god's complete transcendence
and that god cannot
possibly be experienced in that way this
resulted in the great hesi cast
controversy that peaked in the 14th
century when an orthodox scholar by the
name badalam
who was outraged by the hesse cast and
their claims when he visited mount ethos
called their practices and claims
heretical and blasphemous how
could god's essence or light be
experienced and seen with the eyes as
the heza cast had claimed
or as he at least interpreted them as
having claimed
this experience must be of a created
light not that of the creator himself
it is because of this critique and the
controversy around hesitation in the
14th century
that we get one of the most significant
theologians in the history of
christianity
because indeed a monk from mount athos
called gregory palamas would come to the
defense of the hessy castes
against its critics and was so
successful that his theological ideas
have
basically become mainstream in eastern
orthodoxy since then
in treatises like triads for the defense
of those who practice sacred quietude
he defends the hesse cast against
baralam's theological attacks
and he did so primarily by making the
distinction
between god's essence on the one hand
and
god's energies on the other being a good
apathetic christian theologian
he totally and unequivocally considers
the essence of god
in other words god in his absolute
reality as totally beyond
all comprehension or experience quote
god is not a nature for he is above all
nature
he is not a being for he is above all
beings
no single thing of all that is created
has or ever will have even the slightest
communion with
the supreme nature or nearness to it
however when it comes to god's energies
the situation is different
the energies of god are the relationship
of god to the created world
they are the ways that god you could say
manifests himself
to creation and through our experience
now this is a complex theological
doctrine of course that requires a lot
of study to fully grasp
but god's energies are not created
things they are uncreated and are
fully god himself they're not separated
from god in any way
but they are the ways that he
communicates himself to humans and to
the world generally
vladimir lovsky writes quote god's
presence in his energies must be
understood in a realistic sense
it is not the presence of a cause
operative and its effects
for the energies are not effects of the
divine cause as creatures are
they are not created formed ex nihilo
but flow
eternally from the one essence of the
trinity
they are the outpourings of the divine
nature which cannot set bounds to itself
for god is more than essence
the energies might be described as that
mode of existence of the trinity
which is outside of its inaccessible
essence
god thus exists both in his essence and
outside of his essence
god in his essence is completely beyond
all creation
completely transcendent and inaccessible
to any form of experience or
understanding
but in terms of his energies god is
present everywhere
his energy is permeating all of creation
all of existence quote all creation is a
gigantic burning bush
permeated but not consumed by the
ineffable and wondrous fire of god's
energies
this idea of god's essence versus god's
energies
is considered to have been part of
orthodoxy since the earliest church
fathers
but it was definitely clearly
formulated for the first time and most
strongly associated
with the figure of gregory palamas by
making this distinction
palamas was trying to solve the
transcendence versus imminence
paradox or debates and to defend the
practices and claimed experiences
of the hesse castes when the hazy casts
through their meditation practices
reach an intimate experience of god's
light and of union with god
it isn't god's essence that they are
experiencing but it is his
energies quote to say that the divine
nature is communicable not in itself but
through its energy
is to remain within the bounds of right
devotion
so when a person becomes united with god
again it's god's
energies that one is united with not
god's essence
the light of god that is experienced by
the mystic which is considered to be
identical to the light
experienced by the apostles during the
transfiguration of jesus on mount tabor
is again god's energy which is identical
to god and uncreated
yet not the same as his essence
ultimately the defense of gregory
palamas was largely successful
his theological formulations were made
part of official doctrine in two
councils during the 14th century
and is still an important part of
eastern orthodoxy today
because of palomas and his doctrinal
justifications for hesicasm
this tradition has continued to thrive
within the church even to this day
we not only find people still practicing
the hesse cast forms of meditation and
prayer today
but also see traces of the theological
and mystical doctrines and expressions
associated with it
one of the most important aspects of the
hesi cast tradition in the eastern
orthodox church today
is a book or collection of texts called
the philocalia
the philocalia is again a collection of
texts written by various spiritual
masters from within the hesse cast
tradition
including simeon the new theologian
gregory palamas and many others
published for the first time in venice
in 1782
this quote-unquote book is a significant
spiritual work dealing with
contemplation and prayer
quote the philocalia which was intended
by its editors for laypeople living in
the world as well as for monks
is devoted especially to the theory and
practice of inner prayer and in
particular the jesus prayer
it has become the central textual source
for hesitation and its tradition since
its publication
and shows how this tradition while
remaining consistent in its practice and
theory
remains alive and relevant to eastern
orthodox christians today
as always this has been a very short
introduction to a topic that
could be discussed for hours and hours
without doing a proper justice
the hesikass tradition is in summary a
form of contemplation and prayer within
the eastern orthodox church
it inevitably reminds us of other kinds
of meditation in other religious
traditions
even if we should always be careful to
make such comparisons
but i think it also shows us how a
religion like christianity
which many secularized people today
consider to be dry
and spiritually shallow actually contain
some very
deep and vibrant spiritual features
and not just as fringe parts or fringe
aspects of the religion but as central
and mainstream
parts of its doctrine this video is
brought to you by our patrons
and i would like to give a special shout
out to tim
keys adnan chaumet and brian h
k who are three of my new patrons in the
saint category
so thank you all so much for making all
of these videos possible
i hope you liked this video if you want
to support this channel and its attempts
to bring you
scholarly and academic information about
the world's religious traditions
consider supporting us on patreon
through a
monthly donation or through a one-time
donation
on paypal if not then feel free to leave
a like
subscribe to the channel or leave a
comment on this video
and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you